Hey, everyone,
we are in chapter four.
Now, chapter four is dealing with ...
average cost, marginal cost.
We're talking about marginal revenue,
marginal cost as well, and then perhaps some ...
incentive compensation and things like that.
These do align with our chapter objectives.
Let's go ahead and jump into our first question.
A business produces 50 gadgets,
whatever gadgets are at a total cost of $2,500,
making the average cost $50.
Okay, so that's.  That is 20.
Let's go ahead and write that in here.  2500.
Our total cost divided by 50 as our quantity.
And that does give us an average cost equal to $50.
If producing the 51st gadget costs $70 and the sale price ...
is $60, what should the firm do?
So going to the 51st gadget is $70.
So the marginal cost of the 51st unit is $70,
but the marginal revenue of selling that 51st unit is $60.
So in this case, we see the marginal.
The marginal revenue, which means that we can ...
scratch out all the ones that say produce it and go with ...
not produce it, because now we know the ...
marginal cost exceeds what we can actually make from ...
selling that unit.
Since marginal cost is rather than marginal revenue,
we should back up on our production and just stop at the 50.
The 50 gadgets don't go to the 51st gadget there.
All right, let's move on to our next question.
Based on the table to the right,
at what output level should the firm produce?
We have output going from 0 to 7,
total revenue going from 0 all the way to 5,000,
total costs going from 1,000, 5,200.
And we have nothing on marginal cost there.
So that means we're going to be filling in this table,
and we're looking to see if it goes at,
if we should produce at 3, 4,
5, or 6 units of output.
So let's go ahead and fill in this table.
Now, notice that total cost starts at ...
$1,000 and zero units of output.
That means our fixed costs are $1,000.
So marginal cost is just the difference in total cost as we ...
move along our level of output here.
So we simply just subtract the first number minus the old number.
So this is going to be 300, 1700,
minus 1300, 400.
And I'm just going to fill in the rest of the table here.
500, 600,
700, 800,
and 900 as our marginal cost.
Now, the idea here is that we're ...
trying to equate our marginal revenue and marginal cost.
That's what this chapter is a little bit about.
So let's look at our marginal revenue.
That is what is the difference as we move from one output ...
level to the next.
So this is going to be 500, 1,900,
800, 700 from the next one is 600 ...
and our last one is 500.
So at 5 units of output, my marginal revenue is equal ...
to my marginal cost, which is why I would select C as my answer.
Now, if you are also looking at total ...
revenue minus total cost, what you'll also find is that at ...
4 units of output, we are going to have our ...
profit maximized just like what we would have at 5 ...
units of output.
That is 3,200 minus 2,800 is 400.
Let me rewrite that.
We have $400 in profit at 4 units of output.
And we also have $400 in profit at 5 units of output.
But the key here is that we're trying to equate our marginal ...
revenue and and marginal cost.
Because we know that when we look discreetly,
when we look at discrete numbers,
that is when we start looking at numbers not discrete but ...
continuous numbers, what we're going to see is ...
that the maximum distance between total revenue and ...
total cost occurs where marginal revenue is equal to marginal cost.
Which is why we want to go with that answer as opposed ...
to four units of output.
All right, next question.
A firm's marginal revenue is $45 and its marginal cost is $50.
So in this case, marginal revenue is less than marginal cost.
What should the firm do in this case?
You reduce production.
Anytime your marginal revenue is less than your ...
marginal cost, you want to back down your ...
production as decrease the amount that you're producing.
If your marginal revenue is greater than your marginal ...
cost, then you want to increase ...
your production.
When you have marginal revenue equal to marginal ...
cost, then you don't want to ...
change your production at all.
Oops, went too fast.  Next question.
Which of the following compensation structures is ...
most likely to reduce employee effort?
All right, let's look at these one by one.
Commission based pay with a bonus for each additional sale.
That would actually encourage more employee effort.
So A is not going to work.
Performance bonuses for surpassing targets.
Again, that's going to encourage ...
more effort. So that won't work.
Profit sharing for teams that exceed benchmarks.
Again, that would encourage ...
employee effort.
Which means that DEED has to de facto be our answer.
A fixed salary.
A fixed salary with no performance based elements.
Yeah, that's not going to really ...
incentivize employees to do more than what they are just have to do.
So here D will be our answer as the structure that reduces ...
are most likely to reduce employee effort.
All right, our last question.
A firm's total cost rise from $1,000 to $1,040 when it's in ...
when its output increases from 200 to 205 units.
So what we're going to see here is a total cost increase of ...
$40 over five units.
Okay, over five units.
What is the marginal cost of the next five units?
So here if you're looking at the total cost for 5 units,
remember marginal cost is the additional cost per unit.
So one unit, not five units.
So in this case if we divide 40 by five,
we get an average marginal cost of $8 per unit.
So this lets me know that C should be my answer.
That is I would expect as I go from 1040 to 1080,
my total units would also increase by five units.
I would go from 205 to 210 units.  All right.
So that is it for chapter four.
Hope you've enjoyed it.